I'm one of the most popular
entrepreneurs in our current society no
question like super proud of that
accomplishment I also find it intriguing
that I'm probably the one that talks
most about the shortcomings of
entrepreneurship and how many fake
entrepreneurs there are I'm not getting
high on my own supply Kickstarter works
when your [ __ ] ideas bomb when you
know how to write copy when the pictures
and videos are on point when you get a
whole bunch of people that build
awareness for it and it's you know it's
X let me and everything's execution what
do I think about it it works for one for
one percent of the people it's the same
thing I think about entrepreneurship
it's the same thing I think about design
and rap and [ __ ] life what do I think
about cooking good idea for Julia
Child's first of all let me give you a
good piece of advice I don't know I
don't care if it's a thousand dollars
spend 25 to 50 cents on the dollar
whatever the [ __ ] you're up to if it
works then spend the other 50 I get
emails on our heartbreaking [ __ ] work
my [ __ ] face off for 13 years so my
donut shop had 130,000 started an app
bought cryptocurrency [ __ ] tried to
be an influencer and an ass out in seven
months I'd [ __ ] asked out everything
I worked for for you know be smart just
keep making money you know what I mean
you can get caught up in like I'm an
invest money it sounds good
until it's gone
thank you so much real pleasure
such a pleasure nice to meet you
[Music]
stick to your DNA instead of what looks
good people getting seduced by things
and I don't know if that's happening to
you or not but like the idea of like
building a 100 million dollar app is
like in everybody's [ __ ] mind we
switched we had been on vendor central
which is mm-hmm very hard to get noticed
yep
because it controls it so they're just
buying directly from you huh and we
switched to a third party seller now
that's proprietary that was creepy and
edge 100% you have to become no joke
disproportionally educate Amazon
to me it's Amazon and Facebook
more so than Google and Apple from an
innovation standpoint I think they have
a better pulse of the end consumer and
the wants and needs of that end consumer
I respect execution too much and I think
that only being a speaker only being an
author only being a pundit is
pontificating and not doing and I love
to pontificate as my extracurricular
activity to my actual doing I also am
even more excited than my pontification
'he's come from the outputs of my doing
very simply i think it's a lot better to
take advice from somebody who's done the
thing they're [ __ ] talking about
you understand I'm a pure bred
entrepreneur for real for real for real
like documented lemonade stands baseball
cards DNF student long before this
entrepreneurship thing was cool like I
was on it it was me it's who I was and I
lived the first 20 years of my life
scrutinized by adults outside of my mom
and dad who said I wasn't good and I
wasn't gonna make it
instead of entitlement I I was brought
up in adversity which became my strength
I was told that I lost from the get by
every adult outside of my parents so
imagine how easy it is for me to deal
with adversity and negativity and
trolling and setbacks and pressure
it's the [ __ ] dirt that I come from
vaynermedia is now in year nine I've
only really run it for seven years I've
always thought about it long term and
now it's you know nine hundred people
and now it's you know hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue and now
it's a big thing but a lot of people
that started companies in 2009 through
eleven with me my homies from Silicon
Valley and others even though they
raised millions and millions and
millions of dollars their companies are
out of business now Archie first of all
thank you so much for being here
like 950 3 p.m. on a Tuesday this [ __ ]
makes me [ __ ] happy all right why
don't we uh when we go around and just
tell me like anything even it's like you
know don't like stress that it might be
mundane or you're new or like whatever
like what's on your mind what's
interesting to see I totally agree as an
effect the askgaryvee show let's like
build on this let's start getting very
serious about this I think the
askgaryvee show for like the rest of the
year should be the former CEO of Home
Depot you should have seen today's you
weren't in there right now I was you
were watching you saw what I did with
today's interview I made 3 link I made 3
LinkedIn articles right
like I did one about like Y reviews are
broken in your quick hot takes energy so
quick Hawk takes is honestly I didn't do
what's called 360 reviews because I
think that they're [ __ ] yeah they're
[ __ ] because they're no different
than what you were just saying before it
was really make sure that this is the
video so on that note let's whoever's in
the Justin a pink mislead let's go
through my CRM it you know there's
inevitably six real business people in
the Instagram VIP like let's let's start
booking some guests brash Gary B
for merlic CEO of home depot good let's
sit here as long as we can to see how
hot we can get does anybody need
anything for me I've been busy I also
think that we are remarkably not
creative for example how the [ __ ] in
that world are we not doing a throwback
Thursday episode since I put out content
my whole [ __ ] life
somebody here [ __ ] fresh-faced
interns running out coming out of my ass
in here why can't one of them watch
Tuesday June 7th 2007 swine show where
for the first 10 minutes I talked about
things besides wine and maybe I made a
proper prediction about Facebook and
that's the actual episode in the podcast
we could the one thing that I would say
is I think we kicked it I haven't same
injury of saying like I think as a net
score were dominant
and then there's inefficiencies there's
procedural in efficiencies and then I
think that there are unbelievable like I
don't even want to tell you how I judge
your creativity because you play within
the box you were given which makes no
sense because it's the perceived box
you've created for yourself I think we
would be more creative
I think [ __ ] what great so I'm glad you
love it but I think like we need to
figure this the [ __ ] out how we should
be the dominant throwbackthursday
organization in culture and we don't do
anything I've given you [ __ ] 13 years
of content
[Music]
use that audio for the throwbackthursday
episode that we put up on podcast this
Thursday there you go enjoy everybody on
the podcast use that audio
[Music]